one
okay hi everyone welcome to another
episode of
science and technology q a um there was
a
there have been requests multiple times
for me to talk about lisp so maybe i can
do that a little bit i'm not sure i am
the biggest expert on the history of
lisp
so lisp is
uh a programming language list
processing language
uh originally invented by chapel john
mccarthy who i did know somewhat
um who was a
well when i knew him i would say he was
a somewhat cumulative fellow
um with uh who worked at stanford
he had i think previously been at mit um
and as part of the sort of marvin minsky
artificial intelligence effort
and then sort of splintered off to
stanford where he kind of um
launched uh i think the early days of
kind of
artificial intelligence um at stanford
uh he
was interested i think in the mid 1950s
in kind of okay we're going to do
artificial intelligence
i think he was involved in coining the
name even and uh
it's like how are we going to do
artificial intelligence we've got
sort of models of neural networks we've
got at that time finite automata
models where like a switching circuit
type things
um where there are a finite number of
possible states for the system they were
quite popular there was a famous
um conference at dartmouth in 1956
um about automata studies i think it was
called which was a
kind of an early artificial intelligence
conference and you look through the
papers there and there are lots of
things about
um automata theory of finance automata
neural networks a few things about
touring machines
a few things that now would seem fairly
obvious to us about touring i think
maybe
claude shannon's paper about the fact
that you can make a universal turing
machine
with um just uh two states if you have
enough
colors on the tape and things i think
that was in that um
uh that that conference
but anyway in around 1958 1959
um john mccarthy kind of wanted to take
some of the results from mathematical
logic particularly recursive function
theory
um and say can we make a programming
language out of this now that was a time
just to give people some sense of of
timing the
the early languages like 4chan
cobol and so on had just sort of come on
the scene there were early versions of
those
there were various efforts to kind of uh
standardize programming languages very
early in the picture
and in particular this language called
algol was an effort to sort of bring
together all the experts
in in i don't know automata theory
uh grammars things like this and um
invent the sort of be-all and end-all
language i was going to be algol 60 from
1960.
um i don't think algo was ever fully
implemented
um i think that the ideas from algol a
bunch of ideas from algol
sort of populated many other programming
languages um
a bunch of ideas that that maybe i would
consider to be a little bit
pandering to the details of computers of
ways to make loops
and ways to uh i don't remember whether
algol i think algol had
um you know when you have a function in
a computer language
there's a question of what are the
arguments to that function what do they
what do they mean
is it just the value if you say f of x
is
the body of the function f just getting
the value of x
that's sometimes called call by value
and um
the other possibility is it's getting
the name x and if something else
changes out the value of x from
somewhere else it
gets that whatever is named x
is what gets passed as a value to the
function f that's sometimes called call
by name and then the other one that's
sometimes discussed is called by
reference
which is there is x is a
pointer to some piece of computer memory
that might store whatever it stores
and that thing is being fed to the body
of the function
f and there was an effort
uh to kind of classify programming
languages in terms of
how they did call by name call by
reference etc i have to say
when my first language smp uh
was out and about around 1980 or so
um i was talking to i think dana scott
who was one of the creators of this kind
of
whole field of denotational semantics
that was sort of an effort
to make a formal definition of what all
the possible
meanings that programming languages
could have and
i was like this is how smp does defines
functions it's all based on
transformation rules for symbolic
patterns
you know which of these classifications
of call
by x does it correspond to
well it doesn't seem to be any of them
it's a it's a different kind of approach
to thinking about the notion of
functions
um but that's getting us off in a
different direction but anyway back in
1958 or so in this sort of context of
cobalt fortran existed um algol was kind
of uh
had been its specifications were being
developed um
cobol algol just squeaked in
having recursive functions be allowed
you know in fortran for example
if you had a function it couldn't call
itself
that was something that for example when
the c programming language came out that
was a
thing that yeah it's of course a
function can call itself no problem but
in 4chan
because of the way that was set up a
function could not call itself
that would tangle the thing into
horrible knots and it couldn't do it
so in that kind of context
john mccarthy wanted to use i think kind
of the
formal structures that have been built
in in particular recursive function
theory
i'm talking about functions recursively
calling themselves but there have been a
whole
sort of formal theory of recursion that
had been developed starting in the early
1900s
so at the beginning in in around
the early days of david hilbert's um
kind of program for representing
mathematics in a kind of formal
way they've been so the question of what
is a function in mathematics how would
one represent
what could be a function and so the idea
originated of what we would now call
primitive recursion
where a function could be defined like
the fibonacci function or the factorial
function
you know f of n is defined in terms of f
of n minus one and so on
it's kind of a version of something like
mathematical induction you know you
define something
for a value f of n and then you say and
now we have a rule that tells us what
happens for f of n plus one
it's kind of the reverse way of doing
that as a way of sort of doing this
primitive recursion idea
and saying uh you know we define the
value of a function in terms of its
its um other recursive values so to
speak
and and for a while it looked like
premature recursion would nail
every reasonable mathematical function
could be described by this primitive
recursion operations
um and uh then about 1920 a student of
um
of of hilbert's name wilhelm ackermann
came up with this thing called the
ackermann function
which is um uh not too hard to describe
actually but it's a
it's a function which you can show can't
be represented in terms of
recursion although it seems like a
somewhat reasonable mathematical
function and it's kind of the the
ackermann function just to explain what
it is
is when you add numbers together
repeatedly
x plus x plus x that's equivalent to
three times x when you
multiply numbers together repeatedly x
times x times x
that's equivalent to x cubed that's
equivalent to a power
well what happens if you iterate powers
well then you get a thing
uh sometimes called tetration power
towers whatever it's a thing where you'd
have like
two to the two to the two to the two to
the two it gets to be a very big number
very quickly
but so that whole family of of of things
where you are saying um i will take this
operation
and i will uh apply it some
n number of times that thing as a
function of the number of times you're
doing
a number of levels of of operator that
you're dealing with
that is essentially the acumen function
um and that function so that
it's a function both of you went from
addition to multiplication to
powers to tetration that's one of the
parameters and then and the value
is x or something and that's the thing
that you are multiplying
tetrating whatever else that function
was something one could show wasn't
primarily recursive yet it
seemed like a reasonable kind of
function to want to talk about in
mathematics
and actually when kurt godel came to do
his girdles theorem thing in 1931
um he made big use of what called
general recursive functions
general recursive functions don't just
go down and say
f of n depends on f of n minus one et
cetera et cetera et cetera they have a
thing often called the mu operator
which says keep on doing this until some
condition is valid
so in wolfram language it would be like
a nest wild type construct
anyway so in that framework of sort of
the the idea of recursive functions
this kind of mathematical structure that
have been built of what could be
represented in terms of what kind of
function and so on
that was the framework um in which john
mccarthy
uh wanted to make something which is
sort of a more principles-based language
and that was the origination of lisp now
another part of lisp was the idea of
well what would a function
really how would you have sort of
functions in lisp
and that then dovetailed with this whole
idea of lambda calculus that have been
invented by alonzo church
in 1935 of what we would now call pure
functions anonymous functions
in world from language the function
function
is the thing that makes a lambda and so
john mccarthy
um also kind of made use of those ideas
marvin minsky
claimed that john mccarthy had never
really read and understood
um uh actually no dana scott was also
also claims i think both of them claimed
this
that never really understood church's
papers i don't know if that's true
i i would give john mccarthy more credit
than that but i'm not sure
in any case the um so one of the things
john mccarthy wanted to do
in in lisp was was uh uh didn't he
wanted to have this very pure idea of
functions of functions of functions or
functions and it kind of represented all
those things with parentheses
um and uh to to indicate
you know what was the function what were
its arguments and so on uh so-called s
expressions i i was looking recently as
original papers
on this and he had this idea that he was
really going to have these m expressions
these kind of
mathematical notation things where you
have f brackets
even had square brackets x y but he said
for now
because it's easier to write the parser
we're just going to use it with
parentheses
and turns out as is soft in the case you
know best intentions but never actually
got back to doing it
m expressions which look a lot like kind
of well from language
type symbolic expressions were never
implemented and so
so the original lisp was kind of the um
this thing with lots of parentheses and
that's kind of that's been a trademark
feature of the way that lisp is usually
presented ever since
now the original versions of lisp i i
don't know exactly what was done in
terms of their very very original
implementation i know there was a
lisp one there was a list of 1.5 these
were things i think in the early 60s
and they were implemented on the ibm 704
computer
and famously two of the key operations
car and cutter
uh for list um what would those be those
would be um
uh what are those those arrest and first
operations in um uh enroll from language
i think um those were machine code
instructions on the ibm 704
and they sort of got into the lisp
language very early
so i think the very earliest lisps
were uh implemented on these ibm
computers
i think then one of the sort of uh
breakout
ideas in lisp was you know let's use
lisp as sort of a a language
that can represent symbolic kinds of
things and that can represent
symbolic ai whatever that might mean and
one of the sort of test cases for early
symbolic ai one of the things you know
it's one feature of the
history of artificial intelligence that
people tend to say
oh as soon as we have computers that do
x
then we'll know we've succeeded in
building artificial intelligence and
we'll have computers we consider to be
smart
but the goalpost of what x is has
progressively moved over the years
and one of the early goal posts is when
we can get a computer to do kind of
college-level mathy stuff
then we'll know we've succeeded in ai
and so
back in the 1960s there were projects
particularly at mit
i think um that were aimed at being able
to do things like college-level
symbolic integration college level
symbolic differentiation
and so there were a series of of
programs that people tried to make with
um
names like saint symbolic integration i
don't know exactly what that
what that uh stood for and there were
one of the things where people kind of
pulled in different kind of interface
modalities like
oh what if we could actually draw the
formulas somewhere you know let's have
that
technology as well um rather than sort
of factoring it into let's solve the
problem of just taking
an already kind of symbolically
represented thing and working out the
integral
but any case one of the things that
happened was that lisp
became sort of a favored implementation
language
for those kinds of efforts to sort of do
symbolic kinds of things for example in
mathematics
the 1960s mostly around mit and then
when this thing called maxima
started to get built which was sort of
an effort that came out i think came out
of a thing called sin which was a
symbolic
integration program and and a few other
through other pieces
it was an effort to kind of build a a
mathematical computation system
and the so one of the big ideas was
let's do it in lisp
and so for that was invented a thing
called mac lisp
and a mac stood for the multiple access
computer
it was i think a pdp 10 um at least when
i met it it was a pdp 10.
it was a computer that was very early to
the opponent
it was a thing you know the arpanet was
the predecessor of the internet
and that machine was node 236 as i
recall
on the arpanet and you would just type
you know into your
into your terminal you would type at
0.236
and it would say connecting connection
connecting and then you would get
a command line prompt for that computer
the multiple access computer
that was uh at mit physically
and was a pdp 10 made by digital
equipment corporation
and pdp tens had all kinds of funky
things i think they had 36-bit
instruction words as i recall
um the 36-bit words for their memory and
things like that
but any case the the um uh project
mac the multiple access computer this
kind of time shared computer
that would be made available through the
arpanet to the world so to speak
um that was the the thing that there was
a mac
list that was developed that was partly
to
in the in the service of maximo which
was sort of this mathematics thing
i think mac list may have been used for
other kinds of ai sort of
kind of ai scenario experiments at that
time as well
so anyway that that progressed up
through
let's see i i used that kind of thing
starting around 1976.
um i rarely programmed in fact never
really programmed seriously
directly in mclisp um but
um uh and
but that was the thing that was sort of
available through that through that
computer system
then there was the idea of look this
lisp is a good idea
let's kind of make it more broadly
available it wasn't
easy to get it to work on
the sort of standard computers of the
day now remember by the late 1970s
uh one was transitioning from the pure
mainframe computers
to the so-called world of mini computers
so a mainframe computer is a thing
that's sort of in some approximation
only touched by people in wearing white
coats type thing and a thing that
sort of hidden deep in the data center
um of an organization and kind of
ibm was the the longtime leader of kind
of the mainframe world
with companies like um uh
well what became unisys which was univac
and um oh my
not honeywell was it honeywell honeywell
then maybe broke off another piece i'm
not sure
but anyway there were ibm was sort of
the number one computer company making
mainframe computers
the upstart at that time was
particularly this company
dec digital equipment corporation which
became the number two
computer company in the world and it
made among other things mini computers
and um initially it was the pdp one pdp
two et cetera et cetera et cetera and
these got to be
sort of increasingly sophisticated
computers the pdb11 was a particularly
famous one
um and then it jumped from the pdp-11 to
the vax
11. uh vax 11780 i think was the first
version
and the vax was the virtual address
extension
of the pdp 11. it wasn't completely
clear i think what relationship it
completely had to the pdb11
but the big thing about the vax was that
it had so-called virtual memory
so one of the issues is you have a
computer it has memory
you know initially it was uh you know
ferrite core memory then it became
transistor memory
um microprocessor
memory um but
the usual thing was there was a certain
amount of memory that the computer had
and you would write a program that would
have to
uh fit in the computer's memory and it
would have to address
uh data that was in the memory of the
computer so the big innovation of the
vax
was this virtual address extension so
the idea was to have so-called virtual
memory
where there was a certain amount of
memory that was resident
in the actual random access memory in
the ram of the computer
and there was other extra memory that
was
uh could just be sent out to disk
um and so the idea was you know you
could have a program that didn't fit in
the physical memory of the computer your
computer might have
one megabyte of memory let's say if you
were very very lucky
but you might have a program that wanted
to use 100 megabytes of memory
and the idea was that the the data
that was being used in the program will
be sort of underneath you
will be swapped out to disk brought back
again as needed there was this concept
as
it is this concept of an address
translation unit in which
you give it let's say a 32-bit address
and it says
where is that actual piece of memory is
it available directly in ram
or do i have to go to disk to go fetch
that and that was the sort of big
innovation of the vax
um was to make that possible now in a
sense
in modern times as the you know it's
always been a sort of a complicated
trade-off as the price of memory and
semiconductor memory and so on has come
down
and uh there's sort of this question of
does virtual memory really make sense
and some devices like
like uh most mobile devices just don't
have virtual memory
they have whatever they have is memory
that is in the
is in just semiconductor memory um in
the device there's no little disk
spinning around i mean there were discs
back in the
the ipod and things like that had a disk
in it but as
as one went to iphones and things that
the concept of virtual memory i think is
sort of dropped away there
and in a sense as soon as one's using
virtual memory
it's like well everything's going to be
a lot slower because you have to spend
time you know
discs go around at 60 revolutions per
second and you've got to wait for the
piece of
piece of data to come around on the disk
before you can pick it up and use it
so that's kind of a a thing you don't
want to have to do and of course
in the way that memory is actually built
for computers you end up with these
multiple levels of hierarchy memory from
the you know the level one the l1 cache
the l2 cache
et cetera et cetera et cetera things
that are you know on the cpu where the
very most
hottest sort of parts of what you're
computing with
are stored in those parts of memory and
compilers try and figure out what to put
where and
various kinds of other things that
microprocessors figure that out
and kind of the bottom of the pile is
virtual memory put it out to disk
um but in any case back in around um
uh must have been 1978-ish
uh you know the vax started coming out
and there were a number other
uh competing companies data general was
another company
that um uh was in that business
and so they're starting to be computers
big enough that you could really
implement a lisp system in principle
but the actual path that was chosen was
a different path
instead there were a couple of companies
that got started where the idea was to
actually build computers
that in their hardware would be
optimized for dealing with lisp and
there were two companies one called
lmi list machines incorporated another
called symbolics
these were both uh basically mit
spin-off companies
that had the idea of
of um of building sort of a hardware
lisp optimized computer and not only
would the hardware be list-based the
operating system would also be less
based
it was actually a pretty good idea but i
think it was ahead of its time
and always when you're sort of
entangling doing the hardware
with doing the software you've you've
set yourself up for a much more
difficult problem
and those two companies i mean there
were there were sort of pieces of that
um uh that sort of had been associated
with a chess playing machine there's a
chat called richard greenblatt who was
involved with
with lmi as i recall who um had been
sort of a builder of a of a hardware um
chess playing machine and that was kind
of technology that flowed into that
um the so these two companies got
started
and um unfortunately it didn't go that
well
there were companies that started using
these list machines but
it was not a a popular kind of thing
and there was a lot of technology that
was pretty nice i mean they were using
the
the sort of the display technology that
come out of xerox park that you know
bitmap displays
and so on very very forward-looking but
it didn't really work out from a
business point of view
and i think when i built smp starting in
1979
i certainly considered using lists but
it was completely impractical to do it
at that time
that just on any ordinary computer it
simply didn't run fast enough the
computers
didn't have enough in memory it was not
a
a promising thing and so i implemented
smp and c which was at that time an
up-and-coming
uh sort of modern newfangled language i
think john mccarthy was never very happy
that i had done that
because it felt like you know lisp had
defined itself as the language of
ai-like
things and we had a great big example of
something which was sort of ai-like and
not in lisp
well then i i think the a footnote to
history
about lmi and symbolics and so on and i
think one of the people who was
sort of in that orbit um was richard
stallman
um and uh at least i i'm trying to
remember whether he's told me this story
whether he's um
whether this is a mythical story told by
other people exactly what the status of
the story is i'm not quite sure
but the um the sort of the picture
painted was
you know at mit all the hackers
so-called were getting recruited by
either lmi or symbolics
and some of them were getting equity
stakes in those companies and so on
and for one reason or another um richard
stallman wasn't
on everybody's favorite person list and
so
he didn't end up uh going to either of
those companies
and so he sort of said and again this
may be a one of these apocryphal
mythical stories although i'm
i've definitely talked to i'm i'm trying
to remember exactly who told me what and
so on
but um in kind of a a uh
a fit of peak it's like look if you guys
are not going to
you know have me involved in your
companies i'm just going to make all the
software free
and um uh you know that was um
apocryphally at least
um the origin of that um uh that effort
but anyway so so going into uh beyond
that there was sort of
ideas like let's make a standard for
lisp there was a thing called common
list which was an attempt to do that
which became very very very complicated
i'm not sure how fully it was ever
implemented
um in a sense the the concepts there
are things that uh are you know very
much along the lines of things that that
i've ended up building with wolfram
language and so on
and uh certainly uh well guy steele who
was a person who worked on the common
lisp thing
i i knew him at thinking machines
corporation where i was a consultant he
was
he worked there um he was somewhat
involved in the
i'm afraid the the um uh the
complexification of what i thought was a
pretty beautiful
thing called sea star which was a kind
of extension a parallel extension of c
that i had developed for or at least
created the specification for
um for the the connection machine
computer but
um uh it um so i'm not sure how fully
that got implemented i think the
i remember when i was working on on the
early design of mathematica
this must have been 1986 i remember
looking at a common list
book and um uh trying to make sure that
we were sort of covering a bunch of
things
in there um i think that um so you know
those are those
adventures that happened you know what's
often said by people who are involved
with lisp
is you know in the end every programming
language recreates lisp
which is in some sense true because
it has you know it has a certain there's
a certain pathway
to universal computation and it has some
good primitives for that pathway
which in a sense came out of lambda
calculus and recursive functions and so
on and in a sense in my own efforts
to have sort of the best possible
computational language environment
uh i've tried to make use of everything
that we learned from the hundred years
or so of mathematical logic development
that's come before us and the trick
really is is to try and meld those
concepts together
we know they're equivalent but how do
you actually in practice meld them
together
and i think one that's been sort of the
only standout loser
is the is combinators this idea of
of being able to specify things without
any variables at all
the sk combinators invented by moses
schoenfinkel
in 1920 that we were just celebrating
the centenary of at the end of last year
um these are an idea that were very far
ahead of their time
very much defined kind of a lot of this
notion of symbolic structures
as things you could computer not that
moses sean finkel talked about
computation
he more thought about it in terms of
mathematics and logic and so on
you know john mccarthy i noticed
recently in his original paper about
lisp
basically said well in principle we
could use combinators
to represent kind of the way that data
flows into functions and out of
functions and so on
but it's not clear anybody will
understand how these work
and that's been the continuing
experience to today
that we just don't combinators are not a
thing that are very easy for us
uh sort of uh mere mortal humans or
something
to wrap our brains around they're very
beautiful they have
avoid the need to ever name a variable
it's kind of like
a a world where
we speak language without nouns or
pronouns
we we can just say this flows into this
flows into this flows into this goes
into this
because i can't use the word this um but
uh
uh it's kind of just you know you're
defining the plumbing so to speak
but you're and you could sort of feed
anything in at the beginning to the
pipes
but you have this elaborate way to
define the plumbing
and we just haven't in programming
languages to date
and i've certainly looked at this quite
a bit we really just haven't found a way
because in a sense programming languages
are attempting to make and more so even
computational language
is attempting to make this bridge
between sort of
us the humans and what we understand and
can think about and what computers can
can do and so it isn't very useful to
have that bridge
if we don't have something that we
humans can wrap our brains around
now of course the the early programming
languages were kind of
very much pandering to the very detailed
structure of
you've got these registers in this
computer and you have to load them up in
this way and you can move the data from
here to there
my goal in building well from language
and computational language in general
is you know can we get away from having
to worry about how the computer
implements all this stuff
and get to the point where we're really
working with the raw
ideas of computation and the things that
we humans can actually understand
i might just give a shout out to another
uh programming language that originated
not long after
lisp and to me i think was a sort of
great achievement
which was apl it stood for a programming
language
developed by a person called ken iverson
who had been sort of involved in the
harvard orbit
and people like howard aiken who had
built the mark one computer at harvard
and so on it kind of come out of that
tradition
and ken iverson the big thing that he
wanted to understand
was not these recursive structures of
the type that john mccarthy was looking
at
but arrays kind of these sort of
rectangular
sort of multi-dimensional rectangular
kinds of ray structures
and operations that will be done on them
and in a sense ken iverson made a much
more kind of
ordinary mathematics style play at
thinking about how do you think about
arrays how do you have
operations that operate on arrays how do
you
how do you operate on a certain axis of
an array how do you
unravel an array what we would now call
flatten how would you do all these kinds
of operations
and i have to say i never really used
apl
um apl had was a sort of specification
um that uh got created in the 1960s
uh ken iverson worked at ibm and
um ibm actually implemented apl
but one thing which was sort of a very
interesting mistake that ken iverson
made
was he said look he's trying to make
this essential
essentially notation for algorithms that
would represent things like take and
drop in a list and
you know we'd have ways to do that and
apply this function across this axis of
this array all these kinds of things
and he had the idea look we've got
mathematical notation it's got all these
symbols like plus signs and
and you know equal signs and all those
kinds of things let's make a notation
for these kind of computational
operations so he made this notation and
they're things like you know iota
an iota-like thing is what we now call
range
and i think a um
boy i'm not sure whether i can i think
slashes have something to do with what
we would now use but now we slash at and
more from language
map operation i'm not sure but but
anyway
there were a bunch of notations and some
of these notations you absolutely
couldn't find on
on a standard computer keyboard at the
time so you had to have these special
apl keyboards
that would use the special apl character
set that would
introduce kind of the um all of these
sort of new
computational apl notations for
for these array operations i think the
problem was
if it had been just one new operation
that maybe people could have typed with
some combination of letters
on a keyboard or something like that
might have worked but by the time you
have
30 or 40 of these things it's like
nobody's gonna it's too big a cognitive
load
to actually be able to learn all that
stuff i mean the result was
you get these beautifully short compact
programs but they're very hard to
understand
once you've once you're really deeply in
that world yes you can understand them
but from the outside if you're just to
show them here's this program it's like
i don't understand what this does
now in a sense you take even some of
those sort of prized programs
you translate them into wolfram language
and instead of having some i don't know
you know
weird comery thing or instead of having
some triangle that represents
uh grade upgrade down sorting thing
you have the word sort or you have the
word
even map you know you are or flattened
for example
people deal with words pretty well they
don't deal with
notation so well they can learn notation
but they
learn it slowly sort of one operation at
a time so it was too much too fast
and i think that that kind of detailed
issue
of notation kind of doomed that
uh apl at that time i mean i i know i
knew ken iverson
um and he uh uh you know he always said
what he really had wanted to do with apl
was invent a this kind of mathematical
style notation for computation
what i would now say that we've we've
gone a long way with and the
computational language that we had in
wolfen language
although we're leveraging english
basically
as the language to explain what we're
talking about rather than
inventing our new kind of leibniz
outread whatever
sixteen hundreds-ish notation for all of
these kinds of operations
and as i say i think one gets the
opportunity you know maybe once every
five years we get the opportunity
to introduce a new sort of you gotta
learn this notation type
thing um but not more often than that
really
and now we can go back and see whether
i'm right about whether how often it's
been it might be more on average once
every two years or something for
language i'm not sure but anyway so so
but apl
i think the worlds of apl and lisp
although both
i see them as being the two most
visionary early programming languages
um but i think they were fairly separate
worlds uh for a long time i think what i
tried to do in in building smp and then
language
is capturing some of the some of the
sort of best ideas from those languages
i have to say i was
a little bit sad and i think was 1989
i was like the keynote speaker at the
apl annual conference
in new york and uh a bunch of people
there were sort of saying
look you know mathematica is the future
of apl
and uh i remember i had lunch with ken
iverson at that conference and
and um i think he felt that that was not
a bad
kind of uh it was not a bad thing the
the
you know these ideas you know kind of
had a
had a direction there and i think apl
itself uh spun off a thing called jay
and apl so it's always a funny thing
because
in the world of kind of finance and
particularly quantitative finance
there are all these elaborate kind of
technology stacks that get built
by all these different companies and um
uh
in a sense you know the big thing in
quantitative finance
is i've got this incredibly clever idea
for how to
you know get ahead of the market and i'm
going to keep using that idea as long as
it works and by the way i don't want
anybody else to know my idea because if
other people know my idea
it stops being nearly as valuable and so
there's a tremendous kind of desire
to have these sort of very independent
technology stacks
that um would be uh and one of the ways
that i think that sort of the
the ecosystem evolved was that these
different companies
uh ended up often building their
technology stacks
using different uh different programming
languages
and so for example i think um drexel
lambert was kind of the i remember the
last of the pascal
the big pascal houses and i think um
morgan stanley was the big apl
uh uh kind of um place
and i think um uh you know in modern
times like you know
jane street is the big oh camel place
and it's kind of interesting and it's
it's i think it's very nice thing that
that um
a lot of these sort of innovative um
programming languages
ideas get so sort of some extra mileage
through through even just through their
exoticity so to speak
because there's this there's that extra
advantage to exoticity there
i'd like to think that our language gets
used by all these folk
and um uh you know as we build bridges
to these other different languages we're
able to
to sort of get the best of both worlds
but anyway long
uh long story about um
the uh the history of lisp i hope i
covered um uh
the things that were of interest there
um
okay let's see
there are
um
that's an interesting question from
aaron here was control
well actually i think you may probably
mean control equals
used in mathematica before will from
alpha um
no it wasn't uh you know one thing
that's been nice
about you know what are you going to use
those control keys for what are you
going to use those all those characters
for
the ascii character set has remained
very fixed all these years you know
the back ticks and hash signs and all
those kinds of things
it's pretty much been the same set for
the whole time i've been doing computing
i think
i think that the um uh
well no when i first used a teleprinter
to produce paper tapes for computers
yeah okay so there's been a couple of
evolutions of the character set
um first
okay so in the very early days
when people started having kind of a
definite way to type things
not using a telegraph with you know most
code type stuff
the next technology was this thing
called the telex machine
um i wonder when that originated
probably the 1940s
probably it was originally
electromechanical i certainly saw them
in use
by the by uh
my my father's little company had a
telex machine and that was some
must have been i must have first seen it
around 1965 or something
and um the uh a telex machine
at first it was a just you type it sends
a a essentially a telegram
wire out to another telex machine it
would have
a how did that work it had it used to
have a rotary dial
phone that you would sort of dial the
other telex machine
yeah i think you were kind of sending
text messages but
through a phone line like
medium but then the big innovation was
that you could kind of at first you had
to just like type in real time just like
if you're connected with a telegraph
telegraph
you know you're you know you're clicking
that that key and it's going to the
in real time to the place you're going
to but the the innovation that i'm
guessing was early 60s
but might have been slightly earlier
than that was the idea of using paper
tape
as a way to sort of cue up your message
and so what you would do is you would
first
offline you would create this paper tape
which had
a line of holes each character was a
line of holes it was used to be
um five-hole paper tape and that was um
that line of holes each line of holes
and the paper tape
would represent one character you would
you would create the paper tape
and then when you wanted to send your
telex message you would
um uh you would load that into the telex
machine and telex machine
would just automatically sort of read
the paper tape one
one line at a time and send out the
messages oh yes i'm remembering the
issue
the issue was you in the previous
version
you would dial the phone effectively
with the telex machine and let's say you
were dialing to timbuktu
that it could be expensive to have the
line to timbuk2 open
but you as the telex operator was
sitting there just typing the keys you
had to do it as fast as possible
it became a much better proposition when
you could just use paper tape
and you would just you know dial timbuk2
and
you know you could then load in the
paper tape and as quickly as possible
all those characters
will be sent through but that was kind
of five-hole paper tape then the next
thing was eight-hole paper tape
and i guess though developed these two
standards epsodic
and ascii ebcdic was a pretty ibm
oriented standard
oh i should explain in programming
mainframes
one wasn't typically using paper tape
one was typically using cards
so a card is this thing about it's a rig
and uh
a card had 80
uh 80 columns on the card and so would
you
you would use a card punch machine and
um
you would uh you would say you press a
button it was usually a blue button
it would bring the card in and then you
would start typing keys
and the successive columns in the card
would be
punched out um according to the key you
specified and so
when people say you know 80 characters
per line
that's a story of cards and in fortran
the first
six um first six columns as i recall
were sort of reserved and you could put
a comment you could sort of comment out
um a card by by changing something in
the first six columns as i recall
and um so cards were a thing and you'd
have these card decks and so
a big program might be physically you
know a foot high of cards
and the thing that was the absolute
horror was what if you drop your card
deck
and cards are scattered all over the
place i'm not sure i don't think that
ever happened to me
i certainly was aware of people who
dropped card decks
and then then at some point it became
the case that when you would
generate a card deck it would come with
some kind of numbering data i think that
was what was in the
the first six columns you could have
numbers for the cards
and so if horrors you dropped your card
deck you could in principle put those
cards in a sorting machine
and um it would sort them back into
order i mean it's worth realizing this
card technology
had originated back in the very early
1900s um
it was the kind of the hollerith
technology
which was originally used for the us
census for example and was the kind of
original kind of technology of ibm
um was uh card uh was was cards
and being able to do um uh being able to
like sort things according to cards
where you'd literally
you know used rods to sort of pick out
cards that would have these particular
holes punched in them and so on but
anyway that was the technology that was
used for
the mainframe computers and so on um but
then the question was well which
characters should actually appear
in the you know you've got five holes
that means in principle you've got 32
possible characters
which characters should appear well with
32 you only get
um you you only get capital letters you
don't get separated large and small
letters
um so that had to await sort of eight
whole paper tape
and and these um these sort of uh uh
bigger media for representing things but
then the question was
what what characters would actually
appear and i think in epsodic
there are some characters that now
appear on standard keyboards that were
not present in ebcdic
so when ascii kind of won out and that
really happened i would say
uh still an smp in the early 1980s we
had to worry about absolute
as a as a character encoding um i think
that kind of went out
by probably the mid-1980s i don't think
we had to worry about episodic when we
started building
um uh building wolfram language and
building mathematica in 1986
um but uh this question of sort of what
characters would appear
was sort of then very much determined
and uh of course
i remember even from typewriters some of
the characters that we now
have the sort of special characters were
on there like
like for example an at sign was on there
uh originally it was like if you were
typing um
uh you know a a price you would say
um or you would you're typing some kind
of um invoice or something you would say
you know i'm buying three oranges at
sixpence each
so you know that three at
6d h or something and that at
sign was used for that purpose it was
kind of a commercial sign
one of the things that's often confusing
in these days is that the hash sign
is um that hash sign on sort of in the
british tradition
that was the pound sign as in pounds
sterling you know the l with the
decorations
was in sort of that position on the
typewriter and then something which
just is utterly confusing to me the
pounds as an lb
the um uh the weight somehow ended up
getting represented by that hash sign
in some way and then even more
confusingly
when the bell system when att
was um was originally developing a touch
tone phones
they had this grid of of uh of letters
it was a
whatever a three by four grid of of
sorry a three by four grid
of keys that were the you know one two
three four five six etc
and um they let's see they
they added two sort of bonus keys
in addition to the the 10 because they
wanted a grid of 12
and that grid of 12 by the way
translated into this touch tone
tones you know when you press a three
what it would do is it had a certain
location
on that three by four grid and
there were two tones that were produced
that were sent down the phone line
one tone that rep whose whose frequency
represented
kind of the vertical height of the key
and one that represented the horizontal
position of the key
and so those two touch tones that were
hard to whistle
unless you were a bird that can produce
two tones but um that were hard to
whistle
um were the things that represented you
know the number three or whatever
um being sent on the on the telephone
line and this
the um these sort of two extra bonus
keys one was a star
and the other was this thing we now
usually call hash sign um
that the official name for that in the
bell system was octo thor
which i guess came from the eight
tentacles
of the of the of the shape of the of the
character
but anyway that was um so there was a
slow evolution of these kinds of
characters and what could be used and so
on
um but ascii was for a long time the
thing but of course then the question
came up well what about if you were even
using french or something which had
accented characters
or you were using you know polish which
has all kinds of extra accented
characters
or you using cyrillic you know russian
or something or using greek
you know how would that work and so what
happened i think ibm was quite involved
in this
is that there were these sort of
standards for how to
um represent kind of let's say the
the french character set the the um
uh the turkish character set the um
uh the the the russian character set and
so on
and so that became the iso latin one i
saw latin two isolating three
character sets each one kind of the same
set of uh these were eight bits of the
same set of actually 128
possible uh characters but they were
sort of overwritten
so so what in english would be a such
and such character
if you used a different character set
that would be the french accent you know
e-acute type character or it might be an
alpha in greek and so they sort of
evolved these things isolating one
isolating two light and three
and it's like a bunch of languages fit
into isolatin one
and i i don't actually remember now how
exotic it got i'm not sure if the
icelandic
thorn character made it into isolatin
one
but by the time i think some of the
polish characters were in like isolatin
two at least and a few languages had the
sort of misfortune of being and i saw
that in three
and then there was iso greek um and so
on and so for a long time it was
like and we still have this capability
more from language today
of saying it's an 8-bit character but
we're going to have it be interpreted
as a as greek or as russian or whatever
else
it was very confusing well eventually as
computer memories got bigger and so on
and this was
by now in the early 1990s um people
realized that it would be a good idea
to sort of standardize the the notation
for all these kinds of things
and to try and sort of put together
everything in a single
sort of standard for how to represent
the glyphs of the world
and so that's how the unicode consortium
was was created
and um uh we were quite involved in that
and i think
uh uh mathematical morph language we
were one of the first applications to
make use of unicode
which at the time used 16-bit 16 bits to
represent possible characters and so
then
the rush was on what was going to make
it into those two to the 16
65 536 possible slots
in unicode what were going to be the the
official characters that made it there
and uh by the way there had already been
these ways of representing
uh chinese and japanese um in um
uh in using the cjk uh
um way of doing things which were sort
of combinations of characters
combinations of the the 8-bit characters
to represent
some of the 20 30 000 ideograms that
exist in those
in those languages um so sort of the the
race was on in the early 90s
you know what was going to make it into
unicode we were actually happy to be
able to contribute
some characters in the mathematical
space of unicode um
that were things like the differential d
character and things like this
um and there was sort of a a big kind of
uh effort
to see what what were the different
things that might be useful in math and
all these other areas
and i i remember there was a sort of a
terrible moment when
things like i think the language i think
georgian if i remember correctly
had some issues in in not getting
included in some version of unicode
um and uh korean kind of was which takes
up you know hangul characters
have these multiple segments and things
and there were some issues
with that but in the end uh unicode got
created
and it's been a useful standard now of
course like everything
16 bits turned out not to be enough and
so
as people started worrying about i don't
know babel
babylonian cuneiform it didn't fit in
the 16-bit
space of ordinary unit code emoticons
emoji uh you know the the most basic
ones would fit in in 16-bit unicode
but uh when you were you know having an
emoji that represented you know
a a happy fox or something and that
became a separate emoji
and you were kind of recreating the
history of egyptian hieroglyphs or
something
um the uh that that wouldn't fit in
16-bit unicode
and so there was a number of years ago
it's
um uh um it started
to uh uh there started to be this idea
of non-plane
zero unicode playing one unicode and
like baboli and cuneiform
is a proud contributor to plane one
unicode and of course it's a big pain
to um uh to actually update the way that
string manipulation and so on works in
software
to deal with characters that are no
longer you know went from the 8-bit
characters to the 16-bit characters
to the 32-bit characters and there were
all kinds of you know when you store a
big long string you know you're storing
a genome for example you really don't
want to use 32 k
bits to represent every a g c and t
in the human genome because actually
there are only four of those base pairs
and a few more if you include weirder
forms of life
um but you don't need to be using all 32
bits for those things and so that's a
that's a place where there's all kinds
of fancy footwork in the implementation
to make sort of optimal use of that
while not making the code too messy
um okay
let's see well
questions here um
yeah dan is commenting it's it's crazy
to think that the history of computing
is less than 50 years old yeah yeah
right
i mean the thing that really amazes me
is you know at this point wolfen
language is
33 years old and that's
kind of more than half the total history
of of of programming languages
um it's a it's a remarkable thing kind
of how quickly
the idea of computation it's a typical
thing in the way technology works
you know once a methodological approach
opens up
it's kind of like it rushes into that
space and that's what's happened with
computing
although the stack we're building is
really a tall stack
and and it's had many different layers
that needed to be built
uh d0 is commenting the ascii table was
eight bits yes
ascii table is eight bits long it's a
question from dan about have i used
fourth what do i think about stack-based
programming languages
you know i haven't personally used
fourth
fourth was a language developed
originally by radio astronomers for
radio telescopes and things like that
it's a very minimal language where it's
really just a
push things on the stack it's kind of
like the hp calculators
were the other very stack based based
languages
um and it's kind of a very um
sort of the idea is let's have a very
very minimal language which
requires sort of minimum space to
implement
and can be implemented on a very tiny
thing i mean in these days things like
microcontrollers like arduinos and so on
they tend to use a variant of c as their
language
um but there are other languages like
lua for example which is popular in some
games that's another very minimal
language
um these are these are sort of
interesting ideas i mean i i have to
tell a story about stack based languages
and radio telescopes and so on
the um uh years ago
this movie called contact that was sort
of
developed by carl sagan originally which
is an extraterrestrial first contact
movie
starring jody foster as an astronomer
who is notably uses
the vla very large array telescope in
socorro new mexico
to um to kind of um
uh you know first detect the
extraterrestrial signal
i kind of have to tell a story about
that this must have been sometime in the
80s
um early to mid 80s i was like um
with a friend of mine i was um uh was
like um
uh doing a pseudo tourist trip
in new mexico i think maybe at some time
when i was consulting at los alamos or
something
and we thought okay let's go visit uh
the vla
in this vla you know radio telescopes
kind of the shtick in radio telescopes
you've got to be away from civilization
because you don't want all that
nasty radio noise and like green bank
and west virginia has this whole
you know cell phone free town and so on
to support
kind of the don't don't have cell phones
near don't have radio
near a radio telescope but any case so
the vla is in a very
sort of obscure place but i i
particularly
uh was struck and i'm sure it isn't the
case anymore but
driving to the vla and sort of the
middle of nowhere go through this town
that says you know i forget what its
name was that
um uh had been some kind of gold rush
town
and had a big thing saying you know uh
this town had become a ghost town but it
is a ghost town no longer and it had a
picture of the radio telescope and so on
on the sign
but the sign was on a rotting piece of
wood and everything was abandoned
and so it was back to being a ghost town
again i just thought that was kind of a
strange and
a strange thing but any case the the vla
is um uh uh featured in that movie
and um in the movie there's a very
elaborate control system for the vla
and um i uh thought gosh i
uh for some reason i knew people who
worked on the on the visual effects for
that movie
and i also knew radio astronomers um and
so i thought gosh you know when did i at
least connect these folks
because maybe the people who worked on
the movie have all kinds of nifty
software that they've built
that might be useful at the radio
astronomers and so i asked the question
you know in the in the movie there's all
kinds of elaborate sort of
thing for for setting up a observing
process on the vla
said how does it work in real life how
is it actually done
oh well actually we used lotus one two
three macros
to to set it up so that was kind of a a
um
the the the fact is is a little bit less
glamorous than the
than the um than the movie so to speak
um
anyway okay let's see maybe um
uh
gosh all kinds of questions here
i don't i shouldn't go on too much
longer here
um there's a bunch of of mathematical
questions which i'm happy to try to
address
um but in a different place
um it's a question here from a tory
about what's the history of
zero and void through science
yeah it's an interesting question you
know it's like an idea like xero
seems completely obvious to us today
but it was surprisingly unobvious in the
early history
of computation or early history of
mathematics
and you know in a sense why would you
ever want zero
it's nothing there's why don't you just
give the number you want to give it's
two
or something why would we ever talk
about zero
i think what what happens is you see
sort of increasing systematization
in these areas and at some point it
becomes useful to have this notion of
zero and i think
people say there's some there's some
first use of zero that's in some
uh what is it cambodian or something
um source from i don't know i think
you know there are indian uh places
where people talk about zeros having
been used maybe
um a couple of thousand years ago and so
on but i think the
the serious use of xero took a
surprisingly long time to develop
and people had we've got numbers and
you know one two three four okay where
when you know when do we need there
isn't a number at all it's just zero
when do we need negative numbers
strangely
the use of negative numbers as sort of a
routine thing
didn't really happen until people wanted
to do the extremely obscure thing of
solving cubic equations
that was cardano and people in the 1400s
um
wanting and in fact kind of complex
numbers
sort of showed up at more or less the
same time that negative numbers
became routine things to be talking
about people hadn't needed kind of the
streamlined notion of a negative number
before that time it was it was sort of
really forcing
this idea of the casus irreducibleness
the
irreducible case of the cubic equation
that forced
both of these ideas to sort of go get
because you needed a more streamlined
way to represent numbers
and that was kind of the approach there
now it's sort of interesting to see in
more modern times
other examples of that and i see that
routinely in
kind of the things we design for
wolverine language and so on these
concepts that at first
it's like we don't really need that but
then well actually we need to be much
more systematic
about this you know something like
somebody was asking about the
history of things like fold and nest you
know there's the idea of
you've got a list of numbers okay you're
accumulating them you're finding
cumulative sums
of you know first the first number then
the first two numbers three numbers four
numbers and so on
well then you realize that's a general
operation of
folding a function over that list
and so you kind of get to another level
of abstraction and that's kind of like
what i think happened
with things like zero is you know that
that's the way that
that the null thing is um uh is
something that you don't think about
until you're being very systematic and
it's kind of
i would say almost one of the hallmarks
of i don't know i've noticed with kids
who um uh you know are sort of doing
uh technical things and so on any kid
who says
kind of and what about the case of xero
you know what about the the corner case
of zero
that kid has some probability of turning
into a pure mathematician so to speak
because that's kind of the mindset what
about that what about that
abstracted corner case and so on
well let's see uh maybe one more thing
and then i
should go um
um there's someone who's asking here
what about for debts and things like
that snack
asks for negative numbers you know
in in in and now you're going to
probe a piece of of lack of knowledge
that i have but in um
um in the entry
in the invention of of double entry
bookkeeping
the you know luca pacioli and so on in
the 1400s and so on
was inventing 1500s
um uh what is now sort of the standard
method
of accounting well you know there aren't
really negative numbers there's the
there's the credits column and there's
the debits column and maybe in modern
times you put parentheses around the
negative numbers
but that's to represent it's a debit but
you don't really have to
pick up the number and say this is a
negative number
you really the structure is arranged so
that we're talking about credits and
debits
so you don't really have to have this
notion of a disembodied negative number
to deal with uh sort of again an
interesting thing when is
you know when do you go from the overall
structure
is telling you this must be a such and
such to the
the thing itself is more abstracted and
can represent that kind of idea
um there's a question from
ethan about a little bit of personal
history in version one of
language and mathematica um what parts
did i actually write the code for myself
um and uh what was the whole
distribution of of things people worked
on
um you know i wrote a bunch well for
example i wrote the pattern match up
and i was sort of horrified that some of
the code that i wrote in there
was still alive and well today it was
complicated code
i mean it was a a um uh and what was
interesting about that code
was that you know this idea of kind of
pattern matching as a core
aspect of a language was something that
i'd done a little bit of an in smp and
here it was even more
core than it had been in snp or at least
uh
um and the the question kind of was um
in um in uh
um you know you once there was this very
principled idea about you could make a
transformation rule for these
expressions
that have these sort of wild card pieces
in them these so-called blanks and them
um the the question was if you do that
in practice
how do you make that efficient and what
i ended up doing was breaking it into
50 100 cases and you know it sort of
pre-compiles the pattern into all these
different cases
where it can very efficiently know oh i
just have to enumerate these different
possibilities to see whether it matches
and so on
and the what was sort of interesting
about that process of programming was
it was very high judgment programming so
it's something where
well what cases do we need you know i
could have said in principle let me just
write a program
that does all this stuff well it would
have been horribly horribly slow
because in practice i had to make all
these judgment calls oh i'll make that a
16-bit midfield because
that's enough to to take because we
won't have cases which are bigger than
that and so on
and i actually felt a bit proud of
myself because a whole bunch of those
decisions that i made
have held up remarkably well over the
course of more than three decades
of you know uh just how what are the
heuristics that you need to use to do
this or that thing and
it might not have been that way it might
have been the case that things
would be oh the evaluator also i wrote
the original evaluator
um and uh you know it might have been
the case that
things there were um um
uh were kind of um um
you know the heuristic choices i had to
make
would turn out yeah i was okay in so far
as i could foresee what would happen in
the next six months
but it would break years later and and i
don't think it has which is
which is really nice to see and you know
there are a bunch of ideas for example
i had this one of my weird ideas with
collisionless hash codes
where you don't have to worry about
where you basically
are changing the algorithm for the hash
at the time when you create the hashes
so you don't have to worry about
collisions that was one little
nifty thing that i put in that again
might have been
horrible failure but actually worked
well and later on
some sort of computer science methods
got invented that i'm sure we still use
collisions hashes but they may work in a
slightly different way
than the way that i developed them um
but so i wrote a lot of the kind of
the core sort of language part of the
system um
other people wrote uh pieces of um
uh the more kind of um mathematics
algebraic parts of the system um
and uh uh things like well the
the the the notebook front end that got
started in 1987
that was a taiyo gray production um
we managed to pull teo away from being a
chemistry graduate student
to work on the notebook front end
and um uh of course teo in subsequent
years has
has reverted back to some of his
chemistry roots by becoming
the creator of the i think by far most
widely used
pictorial version of the periodic table
and so on
so that's been been a nice thing to see
but um
there were a lot of different different
pieces there were a lot of some things
we were using kind of standard
algorithms some things like a lot of the
language stuff
we just had to invent everything from
scratch a big piece of what i did was to
write
the documentation and i kind of
developed the principle of
first you document then you implement so
to speak
you write the specification first
there's a chap um
uh called jerry kuiper who um
was involved in something which was a
very bold effort
to sort of implement um possible
sort of a very wide range of possible
mathematical functions you know kind of
i had the experience i
really wanted from snp i knew that
mathematical special functions were
things people really wanted and it had
been sort of a
big bunch of work to do each individual
function in smp
and i kind of for mathematica i wanted
to have kind of a bulk machine
for just churning out uh ways of
computing special functions
and i talked to a bunch of experts in
special functions and i think my
my favorite comment was um this was
probably 1987 or so
from somebody saying well we'll you know
you're crazy to want to do arbitrary
precision special functions hundreds of
them
you know anywhere in the complex plane
you know our plan is that at the end of
the 1990s we will have implemented
uh quadruple precision vessel functions
and
and jerry kuiper was much involved in um
the
the building the sort of machine of
having what would
what would now be a machine learning
story um then we were not using neural
nets we were using
simpler kinds of sort of things we could
learn from them where we would bash away
for a month
trying to optimize the parameters of
this approximation to some
particular kind of function um so that
was another person who was um
uh sadly jerry died in a bicycle
accident in the um
early 90s uh interesting interesting
person
see who else who's um still around roman
mader who's still
um uh working on wolfram language um
he worked on a bunch of polynomial uh
manipulation code i think
probably polynomial factoring and things
like this
uh was his early effort and he's also
a um a kind of theory of computation
theory of programming languages person
and uh was involved in some of the um
some of the thinking about those kinds
of things
it's been very satisfying how little of
what was in version one
was just an outright that was a bad idea
throw it away i mean we've really been
able to build this design you know it
helped a lot that i had done snp
first where i had gotten to experiment
with some of the wilder designs
and figure out what worked and what
didn't but you know if we look back at
wolfram language and mathematica in the
early days there were lots of decisions
that could have been made a different
way
for example the decision to make the
computational kernels separate
from the user interface front end that
was you know
client server architecture etc but those
weren't words that existed at that time
that was the decision that we made that
was a really good decision
that um in fact at the time we sort of
separated the software
although for example on something like
the macintosh early on
we couldn't separate it in actual
implementation we had two separate code
bases
and they talked to each other through
sort of a thin pipe but you actually had
to compile the two things together
on some machines but it was very nice
that right from the very beginning
it was possible to use a remote kernel
and so a very common configuration was
you would have your your user interface
running on a mac
and your computational kernel running on
some big sort of mini computer-like
thing and off connected through through
some phone line or through some local
area network
so that was a an architectural decision
that was very good from the beginning
um you know there were other much more
minor things like how are we going to
represent colors
at the time everybody said colors
they're color maps
you just load up a color map it's got
256 colors
you're specifying what the precise you
know color values for each of those
colors is
but i was like no let's not do that the
much more principle thing to do
is just we have an arbitrary rgb color
and it's represented with with three
real numbers and so on
and um if we need to output it on a
device
that has uh you know a limited color
palette
then we'll find a way to do that and um
so that was another kind of good
decisions that are building for the
future
i do remember that we ran into some
trouble with that on some
i think windows machines and i've i've
used that as a kind of a joke ever since
the um eventually you were setting up
all these all these graphics pieces
and they were described as brushes in
the operating system i guess from paint
brushes in an early sort of paint system
and so some one of the more bizarre
messages that you could get was a
the system has run out of brushes and
you kind of wonder you know you think
about that as a
as a sort of uh skeuomorphic design kind
of thing of thinking about these
you know what is it brushing just a very
bizarre idea and
a kind of bizarre word and one that i've
kind of used a little bit as a joke
ever since in terms of of weird things
that happen in kind of layers below the
system we're dealing with
um there's a question here
um uh
let's see the um
um it's a question here about
some how did we develop code at the time
given there was no cvs and git
and so on um that is a really good
question
we had a source code repository and
how did it work i'm not sure we weren't
using things like
rcs the patching system um
we even had a source code repository for
smp
and it's a good question i think people
could do checkouts and check-ins and so
on um
yeah yeah yeah i mean you could do diffs
there was already a diff utility in unix
um but how did that all work
i actually don't remember um
i do remember in snp
i had the bright idea that um for
added security we would encrypt the
source code
and needless to say we lost the key
and finally smp was uh was decoded the
source code was recovered
um by a young chap um who actually works
for us now
um who um uh managed to actually break
i i'd done another crazy thing i'd said
let's not use the standard unix script
program to do the encryption because
if in the world of the future people
break these encryption programs
the first ones they'll break are the
standard ones like the unit
program so i said let's make a modified
version of the unix crypt
program so i did that and uh
we actually had the encrypted code of
the modified crypt program but we didn't
know how it would have been modified
and it turns out that the person who
ended up breaking this
in the end was able to do an interesting
approach to breaking
this encryption that actually never
required knowing the key
it was a way of breaking that kind of
enigma like cipher
without ever knowing the key um so i
don't even know what was that password
that we and
we probably could deduce it now what was
the password that we managed to forget
um it's not easy to run smp it has to be
run in a virtual machine that's
emulating of this it's emulating that
perhaps in the project that we're doing
now with with wolfram language to build
virtual machines that can emulate
i think we've got an emulator of pdp
ones and things like that
um eventually we'll get up to the point
where we can emulate the machines
that could run smp and then we'll be
able to have a an external evaluate of
smp
probably um in world language which
would be kind of fun
um but i'm i'm actually really wondering
now and i'm just embarrassed that i
don't remember
the um uh the details of how
how the early code got got checked into
a repository and um
uh you know we had original version one
of so smp was developed on a vax 11780
computer
where everybody was connected with
terminals that were just
terminals that had you know rs-232 wires
going into um uh the main machine
actually i
i used to i i'm i've been a work-at-home
operative for just
a ridiculously long time and even back
then in 1980 and so on
i used to mostly sort of work from home
but in those days
what what i did was i connected a phone
line with an acoustic coupler
to um to my terminal to the to the
computer
at the office so to speak and one of the
things that i was
just amazed by was i would leave this um
uh i would just leave this thing
connected you know local phone calls
were free
i figured i'd just leave the thing
connected and um
uh the um uh and i left it connect for
months
and there wasn't a single piece of noise
on the line it was just
like i just left it connected i was
guess i was kind of lazy um
and uh i could i could just use the the
computer from there
um i have to say i'm reminded here of a
little micro micro footnote
to everything the person who was the um
uh
assistant secretary in those in those
days
it was called to dick feynman and mary
galman was a
interesting woman named helen tuck um
who uh had um was a
was a um a kind of a
um a spirited person let's say
um and um she was sort of the the
departmental
uh secretary assistant for the
theoretical visits group but
particularly for those
those two kind of luminaries in the
group and before she'd she done that job
for many many years
but before she'd done that job she'd
worked for the phone company
and um at some time or another i
mentioned to her this thing that i you
know i had this thing connected to my
thing at home and she was like you
shouldn't do that it's going to send a
trouble signal to the exchange and it's
you know
that she gave me this whole long speech
about about how
it was uh you know it was cruelty to the
phone company to do that
i figured if they really had a problem
they would contact me and and that never
happened so i didn't worry too much
about it
but um i think helen tuck also had the
um
uh uh she was a interested spirited
person but but
um she uh uh she would tell me from time
to time
uh uh she she had this little office in
between the big office of of
of dick feynman and murray gilman and um
uh you know sometimes i would be
wandering around she'd say she'd sort of
say to me
um oh he's in his office dick feynman
being the person
and you know he's working on hieroglyphs
again go talk to him
it's like because he would uh dick
feynman would sometimes
uh you know if if there wasn't physics
being fed to him or he wasn't
interested in any particular area of
physics he liked doing things like
trying to declare mayan hieroglyphs and
so on
and and helen tuck thought this was a
waste of his talents and it's like go
talk to him go
go to getting excited about some kind of
physics or something
um i think another another helen tuck
story i suppose that was she used to
type papers um it was in the days before
physicists knew how to type
i knew how to type but most physicists
didn't but i still
hand wrote out my papers with multiple
layers of um
of uh white out and labels to make
corrections and so on
and then i would you know the thing was
you give them to helen and she would
type them
and i hear this paper where
um i had a bunch of calculations that
were done actually by
sort of computer algebra kinds of
techniques and this paper was full of
numbers
it's full of numbers like nine and uh
this whole paper helen types this whole
thing
and every nine she turned into a g and i
was like
wait a minute why did you do that and
she says
no paper ever has nines in it nobody has
actual you know explicit numbers like
that all over these papers
and of course the reason was because
nobody used computers to do algebraic
computation
and so nobody was generating weird you
know pi to the ninth over 399
type things and so uh you know
it was the correct kind of machine
learning type assumption
that uh you know kind of the any
anything that looks a bit like a g
is probably a g in those in those papers
so
that was a um uh those were the days
when
the way that you typed a paper like that
was using an ibm
selectric typewriter where and this was
sort of i think the origin of some of
these
character sets we talked about earlier
they would have these golf balls
that would be so that the the typewriter
would uh
um would have sort of an electrical
typewriter
and it would it would have these
characters on this kind of as
as embossed things on on the sort of
golf ball shaped object
and when you wanted to type a particular
letter
the golf ball would rotate around so
that that letter would be aligned with
where it would
where when you hit the golf ball to the
to the ribbon
to the to the paper that would be the
character that got typed
and so what you would do when you wanted
to type a lander or something
is you would go and you would pull out
the golf ball that had the ordinary
english characters on it
you would put in the lamp the golf ball
with greek and then there was a mapping
from the the keys on the standard
keyboard to the keys on the um
uh um uh on the on the um
uh the the the things on the golf ball
so
that you know an l corresponding to a
lambda and so on um
the uh um
it's um uh let's see somebody is
commenting that helen tuck
almost discovered benford's law that
term numbers on average
most numbers at least start more often
with ones than with with nines that
that law was discovered a hundred years
earlier from um
uh from things well let's see
all right um i think we need to wrap up
here
um ethan is commenting no wonder the um
the pattern matter is still still slow
was code that i wrote
that long ago yeah well i've been
pushing
for um for that code to get rewritten
actually with our new compilation
technology
um i think um uh um
i think that will finally happen in a
really nice way
um all right well
thanks for thanks for joining us here
and um
to be continued another time and i think
um next week
is the first anniversary of the launch
of our physics project and so next week
at this time
i'll be trying to give a little bit of a
summary of where we've come over the
past year
and a little bit of where we think we're
going um in the in the
time to come so uh thanks for joining us
and